I spend no time on the cheering or the
boos I spend on executing so that when
it goes to zero zero zero I can say I
was right you got your perspective what
is up Singapore thank you
what up please sit thank you
so couple things I know that it's been a
long day and so what I want to do is
bring as much value as possible so we're
gonna try to do a bunch of QA which I'm
excited about so I'm gonna set up some
framework for where I'm coming with with
my current thoughts on entrepreneurship
marketing kind of certain things I'm
seeing but most importantly I definitely
am excited to open up the Q&A session a
little bit earlier than we had planned
because I think that's where most of the
value comes from so I think the thing
that I want to start off with this this
afternoon this evening is putting into
context something that's been running
through my mind a lot lately which is
perspective what's really fascinating to
me is something that's emerged as almost
difficult to fully understand which is
it's unbelievable that life is as basic
as how do you see it for me I've been
saying a lot lately and have always in
to a lot of people close to me a ninh
that says you find what you're looking
for if you're looking for negativity
it's very easy to find if you're looking
for positivity it's very easy to find if
you think it's going to be successful
you start to see signals that lead to
that and if you think it's gonna fail
you'll see that if you're cynical and a
pessimist that's what you see if you're
optimistic and positive that's what
you're gonna see and really the the
vulnerability to the way I roll which is
optimistic and positivity is you could
come delusional it's not practical you
think you can just dream it into success
you don't understand the requirements
and the costs and the sacrifices that
are needed to actually get somewhere I
think the biggest thing that I've been
spending time on lately from a
perspective standpoint is we are all now
affected by the last 10 to 15 years of
entrepreneurship and when we look at
stories like Facebook or WeChat or uber
away Bo we see these extreme monstrous
successes and they cloud the fact that
for the 15 companies that actually got
to billions in revenue and actually run
actual businesses not predicated on
venture capital there's 80 trillion
businesses that didn't and we spend all
our times fascinated on these enormous
victories without spending our time on
practicality and so for me what I really
wanted to establish in this talk today
is a couple things one the macro
perspective I believe that I'm seeing in
people that are succeeding and when I
say succeeding I think an important part
of perspective in today's day and age is
I believe that the way we define success
is fundamentally broken in human society
we are spending way too much money way
too much time on putting money on a
pedestal and way little amount of time
and energy into putting happiness on a
pedestal the amount of millionaires
people that make millions 10 millions
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
that I know that are disproportionately
unhappy is staggering and I really
really really am passionate about
getting a conversation into the
ecosystem of like what are you at like
why are you here
like why are you actually here today
what are you trying to accomplish and
and do you have enough self awareness
and understanding about yourself to know
what you're trying to achieve because I
promise you over this last
decade interacting with people at scale
publicly and privately what's very
obvious to me is that an enormous amount
of people are trying to get success to
put makeup around their actual
insecurities and they're spending all
their time trying to make money to hide
what's actually happening they're trying
to prove something to somebody else not
to themselves and no level of you
finding a path to making money is going
to solve that issue and so I think that
we're living through a very very
remarkable time in our society where
this device can really be an unlock to
an enormous amount of things but I don't
think people actually know where they're
going and that's something that I've
become unbelievably fascinated with one
of the biggest reasons I've found myself
talking more about mindset and
perspective and things of that nature
was I spend every day putting out
content that shows people exactly what
to do with their personal brand or their
business to be successful and yet people
don't take advantage of the current
state of the internet to achieve their
business goals and after a while I
started to have to ask myself why are
people not doing that and I didn't go
into the Lazy talk of thinking people
are lazy or things that nature it all
led to one big game of insecurity the
reason a lot of people here don't post
every single day is because they're
worried about the judgment in the
comment section of what they post and so
before I get into the details of what I
want to talk to you about from a YouTube
or a Facebook or a Twitter or a podcast
or running ads before any of that I can
give you every single tactic that is
underpriced
but if you don't have a foundational
understanding of what you like to do and
why it's impossible for you
to be successful because we now live in
a world where somebody will outwork you
and take your piece and there's
abundance and there's plenty for
everybody but what has become very clear
to me is nobody beats the person that
loves what they're doing and is good at
it because they're just always doing it
what became obvious to me about
entrepreneurship is I always did it even
when it wasn't cool or in the air like
it is now what's obvious to me today is
there's so many people that want to be
entrepreneurs cuz it is cool today and
it's actually not who they should be the
amount of people in this attendance
today who want to be entrepreneurs or
star companies who would be far more
successful financially and happy being
the number four in a company run by an
actual entrepreneur is staggering that's
not something that anybody in here who's
delusional wants to hear but there's
still absolutely the truth because
anytime a pendulum swings it swings too
far the other way only 15 years ago not
going to college was not even in the
cards especially not in Southeast Asia
and yet now people are debating that and
aspiring to that at scale even if it has
nothing to do with who they actually are
they've just created the perception
that's starting your own company and
being an entrepreneur is the right or
cool or awesome thing to do the only
reason you should be at this conference
at all is for you to find a path to
being content and happy not to make an
arbitrary amount of money I want to make
a million I want to make 10 million I
want to make arbitrary you're just
picking a [ __ ] number out of your ass
what you need to be doing thanks mom
what you need to be doing what you need
to be doing is deploying the greatest
game of self-awareness anybody has ever
done this is one big game of
self-awareness
I don't want you to do what I do I was a
five six seven eight nine ten year old
child who'd rather go and shovel snow
and wash people's car and sell lemonade
then go outside and play I was a kid who
never opened up a single textbook from
fourth grade until 28 that is not
necessarily who you are and so I start
this conversation you know I flew a long
way to come here to create a very
important conversation far more
important than me telling you that
Instagram ads and stories are so under
priced in all of Southeast Asia that if
you start buying ads on Instagram
stories for two and three dollar a CPM
swipe up ads to a direct link to
whatever you do whatever you sell as
important as that tactic is as important
as it would be for all of you to leave
this conference go home
Google how do I write how do I run
Instagram story ads as much as it would
matter for me to tell you that if you
target a certain group of people then
make the content for that group then run
50 dollars worth of ads then look at the
quant data then adjust it and keep
adjusting until your cost of acquisition
is worth your lifetime value as
important as that is as basic as basic
as that is an important and would work
for 75% of this audience to achieve
whatever you want that tactic is
[ __ ] if the only thing you're trying
to do is make money because it is not
sustainable and so look it's I'm really
really hopeful that my opening kind of
ten minutes here sets the tone to what
I'm trying to achieve which is as I
continue to evolve and travel and do all
this stuff the same themes are coming up
over and over and over and I want to
remind everybody here
lived through a decade now of economic
growth and prosperity across the world
we are in a bubble there's so much money
and opportunity in the system that this
is not sustainable there will be a day
of reckoning just like there was in 2007
8 just like there was in 2001 and 95 and
for people that have lived through some
down cycles you think it's hard now when
all the money dries up it gets real hard
let me say it very basically if you
don't have a successful company right
now and you've been operating for the
last two years you suck and I mean that
like I and I'm not saying that I'm not
trying to razz I'm not trying to come
hard I need you to understand how many
people here run a company or an
entrepreneur startup just raise your
hands raise it high I need you to
understand if you're running a company
right now in the globe this is the
easiest time in the history of humans to
run a company so if you're not doing
well you need to really recognize that
yeah you do
and so I'm unbelievably optimistic
because this thing is that special I'm
this optimistic because the little piece
of business advice
in practical terms that I slipped in
five minutes ago I'm gonna say one more
time nice and slow
it will legitimately work for 80% of
this audience Instagram story adds in
all of Southeast Asia except in Japan
and China where other platforms dominate
not Instagram will work for your
business but what you have to figure out
is you're targeting and you're creative
the biggest reason people don't succeed
in running ads on social networks and
platforms is because they don't make
enough content and they don't make the
content for the audience they're trying
to reach they make one piece of
content and try to reach everybody
contextual creative at scale is the game
it's really interesting I've been really
watching a lot of businesses and
entrepreneurs navigate the last year or
so and what's really become interesting
to me is the themes that play over and
over and over again in its most basic
the biggest thing that everybody has to
leave here with is the following thing
the only thing that you should spend all
your time on to really disproportion
grow your business is to figure out
where the customer that you're trying to
reach spends all of their time once you
understand where they spend all of their
time all you should ever do is try to
figure out how your brand your personal
brand your business can penetrate that
attention in the form of organic content
or in the form of bats it's that basic
when I look at the data in Singapore and
I don't know if some of you heard but
vaynermedia is opening an office here in
a couple of months the reason we're
coming to the entire region is that
everything that I've used to build up my
personal brand to build business results
all of that works better in this market
than it even does in Europe and in the
US where we've been doing that marketing
for me the quicker everybody here can
become a media company the quicker they
can become successful
the quicker you think of yourself not as
a salesperson but as somebody who
produces content that provides value to
the end-user
the quicker you will get results the
reason most people struggle with social
media marketing or digital marketing or
marketing or communications is because
their sales people they're not marketers
the difference is very simple when you
look and I did a lot of people tagged
this event tweeted at me so I looked at
twenty or thirty of the accounts here
over the last 12 hours when I look at
your
counts everything is selfish everything
is about what you're selling what you
want them to do for you all the content
is there to get more likes to get more
followers for somebody to buy your
product go into your funnel create a
capture of data at the top so you can
remark it to it it's a hundred percent
selfish that is exactly what all of you
don't want in your normal life from the
other people you consume but it's
exactly what the far majority of people
are doing with their own content for
their own business this is one big game
of being over selfish
instead of being selfless one of the
reasons the biggest book I ever wrote
was called Jab Jab Jab right hook was it
helped so many people understand a
different framework which is you have to
give you have to give you have to give
and then you can ask for something the
problem is when people ask they expect
the disproportionate reason that I see
businesses be successful and definitely
personalities be successful are the ones
that give without expectation because
the content when they give is not loaded
with intent to be selfish there's a lot
of people that give but it's a half give
it's actually an ask
disguised as a give what's happened is
there's so much content now on the
internet there's so much supply of
information as remarkable as these
channels are what's amazing is that
every one of you can be in it the
problem is every one of you can be in it
so what happens is the cream rises to
the top so what's happening is it's very
hard to break through if you're being
selfish because somebody else is being
selfless this is how life has always
been
the maturity has now hit this device a
couple things I want to talk about
before I go into Q&A number one you have
to figure out as a person as a business
how you communicate to the world there
are three ways written word audio and
video too many people are trying to do
video when they're not capable of it too
many people are not realizing written
word is remarkable and they're getting
caught up in pictures because instagrams
popping so the number one thing that
would really matter to me as a data
point is the following I believe the
more content that you put out the more
likely you'll be successful I believe
that you have to reverse engineer the
end consumer that you have to bring as
much valuable content to them as
possible I think that you also need to
eliminate friction between your message
and the customer what that means is you
have to show up everywhere to the best
of your ability in the way they want to
consume it how many people here listen
to my podcast raise your hands
thank you real quick hold them up real
quick watch this everybody look around
keep it up listen to my podcast now keep
it up keep it up I want to show
everybody something if you did not
listen to my podcast two years ago put
your hand down
what everybody just saw what thank you
very much what everybody just saw is not
only the rise in my popularity you are
seeing the rise of audio consumption how
many people here now listen to more
podcast than they did three years ago
raise your hands
look how many people here now when they
watched videos online actually don't
even watch the video they just put it
down and just listen this is what
I spend all my time on I didn't go all
in on my podcast for my health I went in
all in my podcast because I knew that
you started listening to more audio not
read as much not watch as much video at
the same token probably the best best
and biggest piece of advice that I can
give this audience today is a really
interesting one when I wrote my last
book crushing it I did not even talk
about LinkedIn wasn't even part of my
book as I stand here today as somebody
who spends all his time trying to figure
out where the underpriced attention is
the number one place that's emerged for
me in the last three to six months has
been LinkedIn how many people here are
producing content for LinkedIn raise
your hand nice solid but an extremely
low percentage of this audience if I can
leave you with another tactical piece of
advice today it is for you to get very
serious about LinkedIn it is grossly
underpriced attention its organic and
the amount of reach it's getting even
for people in here who've never posted
once is remarkable so LinkedIn written
or audio or video content in a post
remarkable growth it reminds me of
Facebook in 2012 and I believe a lot of
you whether you're b2b or b2c or how
many people here have a job raise your
hand job how many people would like to
leave their job and start their own
business higher the number one tactic I
believe that can make 30 percent of the
hands to just went up have a practical
transition from going from a job to
having their own business is strictly
just blogging on LinkedIn on a daily
basis around opinions and thoughts they
have
in the business that they're in or want
to be in simple as that the game is
based on action the game is based on
action and for me the action that is
most required is to be a content
producer I genuinely believe that no
matter what your ambition is in this
room that if you are not producing
written word audio or video for the
internet on a daily basis you will limit
your upside and you will become
vulnerable to competitors
that are trying to reach the same
audience you are this is a very
important mindset because what's
remarkable about this is what I'm
actually saying is everybody in here
needs to think more like a publisher and
a media company than what they actually
do for a living are you a lawyer cool I
also want you to write content every day
are you a financial adviser awesome I
want you to write content every day are
you a salesperson are you a tech SAS
founder are you this that the other
thing the Gateway to everybody's
ambition is content because
communication is the foundational aspect
of how everybody makes every decision
the reason there's so much scrutiny on
big tech companies all over the world is
because our attention is now there and
that is changing our opinions about
everything there's a reason that when
there's a coup in a country they go
after the newspaper radio and television
first even before they raid the palace
they go for the media because the media
dictates how you think a scary amount of
every opinion in your head was put there
by the content you consumed by the
content that your parents consumed and
then put into your head your ability to
put content into the ecosystem and
create the outcome that you aspire to is
the fundamental variable this can
pewter in my hand is more powerful than
the computer that Ronald Reagan had
running America only 3040 years ago this
is a remarkable shift in our society and
what's scary to me is how few people
actually go all-in and take advantage of
it how many people here consume my
content there's nothing I've said that
you haven't heard before I pound this
message every day every day I come and I
give it on stage because I'm hoping
maybe because we're in person you hear
it this time or maybe because something
happened yesterday you hear it this time
I have the reason and by the way I think
especially in this section first if you
have questions you should line up right
away because I'm gonna go into Q&A and
then I'll open it up to everybody else
so if you have questions you can go to
left and right I'll start I come here
and pound this message because the
reality is is life is remarkably simple
everybody over thinks this stuff
dramatically you've heard this from me
consistently this is exactly what is
going on in our society I'm just trying
to figure out how I convinced you to
start actually making I believe that
producing content on the internet for
you or your business is the equivalent
of working out in the gym every day
there is no shortcut but the results are
there when you put in the work I'm
trying to figure out why you're not
that's how I've gotten into insecurity
or keeping up with the Joneses or why
I'm mad at every goddamn parent in the
world that's how I got there because
there is absolutely no lack of
information if you consume my content of
LinkedIn or podcast or Instagram as a
matter of fact as many of you know I
yell all the time don't listen to what
I'm saying watch what I'm doing if I
have a vlog there's a
if I'm posting on LinkedIn there's a
reason if I'm using more Instagram TV in
my main feed on Instagram there's a
reason there's a reason and so I'm just
unbelievably passionate about people
figuring out the framework and then more
importantly figuring out why they're not
doing the framework and then more
importantly what are you trying to
accomplish that's the question
because we have to accomplish happiness
that has to be the goal and if you
actually pressure yourself to be happy
versus pressuring yourself to be a
success then you have a totally
different conversation with yourself
then you have a totally different
conversation with yourself and when you
start doing that for yourself not to
prove it to your spouse or your siblings
or your parents or the people you went
to school with then it gets really good
it gets really good when it gets really
quiet and it's super quiet for me I
don't hear the claps and I don't hear
the boos I just navigate I love my
process
I love the pain of being an entrepreneur
I love that it's lonely I love the game
I just want you to love the game thank
you I left a lot of time for Q&A because
this is where it's gonna get good let's
go my friend what's your name hey there
Gary
my name is Nemo LaShawn it's a pleasure
to meet you thank you yeah this is my
first time really getting into your
world please that last thing you said
really bothered me please you love being
lonely yes you asked why am I not taking
action it's because of the loneliness
let's talk about it right I am someone
who is highly relational and I've been
generally speaking I'm an outlier a
pioneer maverick and anything good idea
one of the first one of the only or one
of a kind
okay and it's very lonely out there so
my question for you is like I want to be
able to build the next stage of my
business through relationship and I want
to be able to do it and I think the
question that's really coming out is do
I have to come off as an expert can I be
there with people can I can I record
conversations I love document don't
create yes I record conversations with
people that are just real and put it out
there I want to be able to create this
one place where it maintains the
relationship without me having to be an
expert cuz honestly I'm figuring it out
too it's a great question brother I
appreciate you saying it the biggest
issue in our game right now is people
thinking they have to fake it till you
make it guys faking to you make it was
good when the internet wasn't around
now people hear the [ __ ] coming out
of your mouth every single kid that's
ever tried to fake it until she or he
made it in a meeting with me lost
because I'm like this person's full of
[ __ ] they're out no you don't have to be
an expert as long as you don't say
you're an expert do you know why I love
QA cuz I'm not scared because I'm gonna
answer all your [ __ ] questions and if
I don't know the answer I'm gonna say I
don't know and that doesn't make me any
less capable of standing on this stage
in fact it is the reason I can stand on
this stage bro we grew up in a game
where people fake it to them thank you
thank you I know I know the world we all
grew up in
I couldn't believe in social media more
I couldn't believe in Instagram more but
Instagram and social media is where
everybody is faking it everybody is a PR
agent of themselves everybody's showing
the highlights social medias highlights
that's why I like putting up the reason
I started dailyvee was to show you that
if [ __ ] was a grind it's not private
planes and parties and [ __ ] Rolexes
it's [ __ ] work and so yeah bro you
can as long as you position it upfront
that's it you got it
I get it my name is my hair I'm from
India especially flown down thanks
especially for you thank you so I'm
really fascinated the way you are and
the way you you know Provo project
yourself as being so raw and one of the
things I want to know no [ __ ] suit
yeah I know [ __ ] suit I mean I like
the t-shirt I like your sneakers and I
love that and that's something which I
am proud of I'm starting a digital
marketing agency back in India I have
two businesses which I created and I
want to now fascinated about digital
marketing you're the first person I mean
I won't look up to I want to ask you
that the world is moving into doing
things by themselves you know personal
branding is one of the most important
thing people companies are also doing it
by themselves so energy yeah so where do
you see where do you see the agency
being the support system for for the
companies for smaller companies for that
matter it there gonna be a service if
they're best okay it's the same thing I
just said the best part about social is
we can all play the worst part is we can
all play agencies have to be better if
people are taking things in-house okay
and could you give some tips about how
do we you know how do we give a get an
edge against the the rest of the gang
because this be great at what you charge
people for okay yeah alright thanks a
lot thank you for it I know it's super
simple it is like why the [ __ ] would I
pay you if I could do it myself I would
pay you because you're better at it yeah
why do people hire a cook cuz he or she
makes better food than they can or
because they value time absolutely
companies will always outsource and
always insource things man it's one big
game of value absolutely you have to
explain to me why I should hire you
right absolutely this is why I when I
started vaynermedia this is why I worked
for free when people came up to me and
said you know that was my next question
you're starting your office in Singapore
can I work for you for free
hell yeah yeah as long as it's legal
here in Singapore I don't know what the
[ __ ] rules are yet but you can send
me an email
yeah absolutely
thank you guys hi hi Gary how are you
welcome to Singapore I don't actually
have a question for you I'm here because
I wanted to come to thank you personally
December 2016 my fiance died in a
motorbike crash overnight and that meant
I had to take over the company from
being number four to number one
overnight and I had no idea I panicked
and and also I found your content and I
had it I had it playing for like six
months
every day for like 48 hours there you
know like blaring through the house and
and that positive voice in the
strategies the advice just the
guidelines really helped helped me a lot
and the companies are in great now we
were fine we're growing and we're
healthy and and I just wanted to say
that I decided to put your voice in my
head because it's the closest to my
fiance's except it's in English and and
I'm extremely flattered and so I I came
here because I wanted to say thank you
for all the content that you put out
there it's really great it's helped me a
lot it saved my ass and you rarely get a
chance to say thank you in the person
I'd like to do that thank you very much
thank you so much
hey there Gary met from Australia and
here with my sister Fiona as well things
have been a great mentor to us really
appreciate it you met curious what is
the structure of your team lot look like
for you to drive your brand and what is
it going to look like in six months time
and why it's a great question so anybody
who's looking to go crazy extreme like I
have with content on an individual basis
I believe that you need a writer I
believe that you need a video person who
can not only capture but can post
produce and publish I think you need a
designer image so I believe those three
things are completely required to go all
in you probably then when you have three
people and you're busy you probably need
an architect of that that three person
team who can synthesize you and manage
that team some more than a project
manager actually did you say I could say
notice how I use the architect versus
project manager I think a project and by
the way project management is saved
Vayner so I don't want to downsize this
but the way I think about it just to and
I wouldn't even use project manager
because I put such a pedestal you need
somebody who thinks and makes people do
who not just somebody who takes
direction from you and makes people do
cuz you're busy yeah you know I think
the big thing with me that's so crazy is
I know that I'm Gary Vee I've run a 200
million dollar thousand person global
company every day I'm the CEO and CIO
I'm not in an ivory tower I'm in my [ __ ]
I'm on HR calls I'm on strike so I
figured out this by accident right these
all these pieces of content you see is
me living my life and it's just being
captured and it's only ten percent of my
life so you need those people I think
you need an audio engineer similar to
the video person somebody you can strip
the audio and upload to a podcast cuz I
think a podcast and audio content is a
requirement in six months so look you're
talking about a four or five person team
awesome thank you you got it
hi Gary how are you Eric
I'm good thank you my name is Mary I'm
from Indonesia um to be honest before
last year I don't know who is Gary UD he
never heard of you before
but I attended NAC last year and I
listen to you I follow your advice
create content every day and it helps me
that's how I grew my I have to millions
followers in Instagram right now and
that's how I grew my youtube with 1.5
million subscriber which is growing so I
thank you for that so my questions to
you is simple you mentioned that create
a video that you care about not creating
some things that you think will be
popular and I totally agree with you but
at the same time you also care so much
about how the your audience your end
user react on your content so how do you
balance between the two by producing
every day I mean like think about it
yeah when you produce so much content
today I'm just gonna make something I
want to make because tomorrow I'll make
something that you want me to make when
you're not crippled every single piece
of content you can accomplish everything
the framework of producing content every
day gives you permission to do many
things when you look at it over a year
not over a day okay if you're crippled
by every piece of content well then you
have a struggle when you realize that
you're putting out 53 pieces of content
this week or seven or five well all of a
sudden you can do whatever you want on
every individual piece of content
because you don't have to achieve both
contrarian goals in a single piece of
content the reason I just put out that
piece of content is everybody's falling
into a trap of making content that works
on the platform or you know what works
so you keep doing it but then eventually
it becomes boring for you or for them
it's very important to mix up your
content
otherwise it becomes stale either for
the person that makes it or for the
audience that consumes it it's why I do
QA the first 20 minutes was something
you've heard 5000 times I just believe
in it so much that I will say it every
day for the rest of my [ __ ] life it's
now when you may hear something
completely different that's why I
innovated to QA to put me in a position
to make it more interesting okay
you got it thank you you're welcome
thank you hi Gary how are you good
my name is Vikas and I'm from a business
family but I was on a spiritual journey
so at the age of 29 I had my own
awakening sort of like a spiritual
breakthrough yes and I left my family
I've left the family business as CEO I
started from all over again zero yes and
I was on a mission to give wisdom to the
world
okaying wisdom to the world amazing and
I've been doing that for the last 20
years to businesses he owes people in
general it's amazing teaching people
about mindset and meditation now I want
to grow the grow the brand grow this
scale the business to reach more people
globally yes but now I hear a lot about
that no one wants wisdom bring it to the
business everyone is caring about making
money who says that people on platforms
like that they're wrong what do you
advise I do to bring [ __ ] wisdom
what would be the strategy to take it
out of what I'm doing and bring it to
more people around the world millions to
give the wisdom for free okay like me
thank you and you know this when you
have no money you want money when you
get the money you want the wisdom
everybody is on their own journey there
is no right answer whether I say it or
other people said something else which I
don't know but I'm sensing you need to
do you legacy is greater than currency
that's a good thank you I like it too
thank you
hi Gary how are you my friend hi I'm
good
so my name is Tom and I'm a watercolor
artist in fact I have a porter team yeah
very nice painting that I'm gonna give
to you later backstage and take a photo
of you sure can thank you
so my question is as artists what is the
best way to the rich on the visual
quality of art to actually promote my
online courses on YouTube and to gain
more followers and to give the most
value so you notice you know this is I'm
glad you said that when you give you
have to give the second I hear my I like
online courses were you and many others
and I don't know what you're doing could
get caught
and when I say could ninety-nine percent
when you know that you're putting out
something for free that what you really
want is for them to sign up for your
online course you're [ __ ] dead guys
there's a reason you like me more
I'm not trying to funnel you into
anything I want nothing from you I want
you to tell me the story that young
woman just said earlier that's what I
want you know much better that feels
then signing up another person for my
$6,000 thing that bro
because if you're putting out content
you have a visual product you should be
dominating the reason you're not
dominating is every time you post you
hope they go to your [ __ ] course
don't do that just put out great content
and a funny thing will happen they'll
sign up for your [ __ ] course the
intent of content is the variable of
success let me say it one more time for
the people in the back the intent that
you have when you put something out is
the variable of how well it will do amen
to that
that's how you'll win when teach people
how to help them then you will get the
Karma in return and you will sign up
more people because when you're putting
out content and they can sense what
you're actually doing is trying to get
them into the funnel to pay you you're
finished and that's what everybody's
doing and yes there are plenty people
that are successful I know landing page
optimization I know I get it I
understand I understand funnels I
understand it's a short-term game and
every day that goes by its losing
leverage not gaining leverage I'm gonna
make sure of it
got it yeah thank you you're welcome
hi Gary
my name is Fang Jing I'm a personal
trainer I heard your message about being
selfless
instead of selfish and yes I also heard
your message about producing content
daily yes yeah so when we produce
content daily and you you're saying to
the Indonesian lately did you just
produce what you want right you just
produce what the thing is important but
what do we do we leverage on the tools
available like buzzsumo
maybe we want to tell the customers what
they want do or do we just go ahead and
produce what we want both doesn't matter
both both this is the part that people
keep struggling with they they analyze
things at a surface level not at a macro
level like when you put out content
every single day you can do anything
guys my number one successful post on
Instagram in the last three years was me
eating blueberries a couple weeks ago
that's [ __ ] crazy
but that meant that you guys have been
getting so much of one thing for me
that's a second I gave you something
else
you liked it you can do both
that's what volume of content allows it
allows creativity it allows you to be
selfish and selfless so do we like
splice a bit of marketing inside or just
give it up for free
okay thank you very much you're welcome
Gary Hayden I'm Paul Evans a Billy
recruitment for 20 years I've been
living here for ten five years nan Kong
five years here in Singapore love it
understood
I worked inside the bank and I've been
recruited for investment banks for that
whole time yes all here in Asia and I I
joined LinkedIn in 2004 that's the only
social media platform I actually joined
write sad as it sounds and uh I didn't
post anything until two months ago had a
cycling accident and I shattered my
collarbone sorry and I had a titanium
plate put in and I did a video straight
after because I just felt there was a
connection between people's careers and
some of the observations I had through
the experience of the accident
interesting anyway so I just put that
out and about 8,000 hits and I was
shocked so on the bed of the hospital
after the operation I made another video
for one minute and made another
connection and the message is really
people not to beat themselves up
essentially but the one concern I have
now is if that's from January startup
Paul but actually if I join a
corporation yet I want to put out
content yes in the same manner yes which
is you know it's from the heart it's
free I'm not looking for any kickback
round you don't have to overthink the
politics of it right so if you're in a
corporation is perhaps people are here
you know how do you manage putting
content out whilst you have a banner or
a brand that you represent in the market
without having to go through layers of
approval every time before you want to
share something meaningful to people in
your industry
life is about decisions there are many
organizations that you will be able to
join that will not give you any
headaches to do that there will be far
more that won't let you do it nobody's
forcing you to work anywhere if you're
deciding that the stability or the
income that you're getting from that job
this is you know I'm in America cannabis
industry is going through a big
transition right and you can't run ads
for cannabis companies on Facebook and
Instagram it's against the terms of
services as America figures out its
marijuana cannabis laws I go speak at
this event and all these people come up
to me they're like Facebook's screwing
me Gary [ __ ] instagrams [ __ ] me
I'm like no it's not they tell you what
the rules are you don't like the rules
you try to start an account they shut
you down I don't like that Companies Act
want to be capitalists but then treat
their employees like it's communism
right which is why I don't do it
everyone I don't my employees can do
whatever the [ __ ] they want they get
started vaynermedia within the company
do content and steal my like I don't
give a [ __ ] cuz I'm not scared but the
reality is you you have to make a
decision are you gonna maximize your
salary and not give a [ __ ] about that
rule or are you gonna go find a job
right that PC maybe a little bit less
but gives you the freedom you're looking
for it's as simple as that like that I'm
happy right what's that like blended I'm
happy right that's right
here's what I love when you really tuck
this what I love qnet like when you have
a logical conversation the great thing
is you're in charge I understand what
you'd like to happen and I say to you
hey you can take this $237,000 your job
that doesn't let you or do you want to
take this hundred fifty thousand dollars
your job that does
I think what's remarkable is people are
starting to realize the second job is
starting to make sense and that is not
how we grew up the last 80 years when it
was maximized money now it's maximize
happiness and opportunity because if you
take the 150 and you do your content
what you already know you've already
tasted it is your only three years away
from making 430 on your terms right
correct
you're awesome thank you thank you
hi Gary hey Dee Rock is next firstly I
want to start with saying that you're my
inspiration you're my role model you're
my mentor thank you and thank you it for
everything that you do thank you I'm
thank you for a sticker as you're
wearing yeah I'm another Indian that has
come especially for you I came to know
that you are coming for this event and I
thought this is the best opportunity I
could get to see you life my question to
you is in an earlier interview of yours
you had spoken about having a chip on
your shoulder that push it will do even
more
what is the chip and what if someone
doesn't realize what that [ __ ] should be
for them one more time I won't
understand I understand the chip and
each other
what are you asking so what is that chip
for you for me yeah the chip for me was
that the first 18 years of my life the
entire world besides my mother said that
I was gonna lose I'm 43 years old I grew
up in an America where going to a good
college was the only indicator of you
being successful and I was a DNF student
so every teacher I had and all my
friends parents thought that I was the
loser kid in the neighborhood and what I
thought was they were the losers I was
right
so my chip my chip was I was an
immigrant I came to a country I didn't
speak the language like you know I was a
terrible student every place in my life
was telling me no no no except one place
when I sold lemonade when I shoveled
snow when I sold baseball cards there
was this one place where there was
nobody's judgment it was just the market
just the market decided and that's where
I was best the market not somebody's
judgment and that that was my chip for
love question what if someone doesn't
realize what that chip is for them then
they won't be able to execute because if
you are not self-aware about your own
feelings you are vulnerable the question
is are you not willing to look a lot of
people in this room aren't willing to
look because it's to pain
to know where it's coming from when most
people's biggest problem here is
apparent that's not fun that's not fun
and so I'm empathetic to that oh one
last thing
if you could sign my copy of crushing it
after this because that book is my naive
well [ __ ] let's do it right now changing
lives is what I'm here to do thank you
very much
this is some real great [ __ ] service
around here you guys have thank you
go ahead hey Gary I'm big fan thank you
I like your show on YouTube especially
when you pick up just like a random
phone call from people yes and I see
that you know a lot of a lot of advice
you gave them is either going over your
fear and also crushing ones ego now I
was a US Marines before I open my own
business so what I want to ask you is
how do you identify if you are taking
action based on egos when you're kind of
like immersing that lifestyle for quite
some times and if you find out how do
you destroy that you know like what's
happening with you
I think let's talk in in some cases I
could be because though it's not
confidence egos insecurity right you
know when you're scared or nervous or
not confident a lot of people have DNA
that makes them overcompensate I call it
a cactus they're a cactus they're tough
on the outside but they're soft on the
inside the reason I keep telling
everybody kindness is a strength is I'm
super nice and super passive actually
and like I'm willing to let people take
advantage of me because I'm strong
inside so the question is you have to
just know if you're nervous if you're
using you know fake confidence to
actually hide something you're concerned
about humility is an incredible strength
that many men and many people never want
to show
I talk Mook guys I put out content more
about me passing on uber and losing than
I do about the things I win on everybody
else puts out content of fake wins
that's the difference you understand yes
so the question you know this is only
something you can answer when are you
most insecure how do you then act when
it happens and if you front that's your
defense mechanism and you need to
understand that because the way I mean
the way I will run my company ideally
since I was brought up in a military you
know everybody got to do a certain way
if not they'll get hammered for it the
problem I know it's not gonna work it's
not gonna work it's not gonna work
because they have options right in the
military when you sign up and your
sergeant or general whatever [ __ ] it is
like [ __ ] you like [ __ ] I got you've
got to [ __ ] do it
yeah in a business or like that's good I
quit when you run a company you work for
everybody
not they work for you and so yeah but
that doesn't mean that there's plenty of
things you've learned that are amazing
like and by the way for many people
you're that system will work you just
have to know that as a leader there
isn't one thing that fits everybody
so either you find people that it works
for or you develop the ability to manage
people differently than just that way
that you decide you don't have to do it
the way I'm telling you to do it you
could just spend all your time finding
people that like the military way and
they like that vigor I believe to scale
you have to have multiple ways to
address issues leadership things of that
nature you got it you got it
hi hello Gary yeah I'm very rich our
route 32 this year so I'd like to thank
you because I've been following your
content for a long time thank you and
then that has really inspired me in my
entrepreneurship journey thank you so
for me is that I actually in the past I
also was one of the guys that in Sakura
schools I was turned down by teachers
almost ran out of schools that I would
strap myself work full-time there at the
same time do up my business so I got a
chain of high restaurants and food cuts
in Singapore very nice so now the
question is that money doesn't really
motivates me because along the way I
realized that I taught that I'm after
money but now I'm not really exactly
wealthy but I'm think I'm comfortable
but money just doesn't motivate me any
like the process yeah and I feel I feel
along the way I discover what I truly
love is dead
every time I face of problems ironically
I feel a bit happy because once I
overcome that problem I get to share
with people and then I realized that my
true desire is to actually impact
entrepreneurships
to inspire people to continue to find
their purpose find their voice in life
and then now I'm stuck because I do have
employees that I'm actually focusing to
help them to bring up to the next level
but at the same time there's an inner
desire of me wanting to share this and I
don't know whether do I need to continue
to build my business and then share it
later and impact lives later or do I do
it concurrently and what are the
contents I should put up to the market
do it now
concurrently concurrently right I'm
doing it right like there's you know you
have permission cuz you've lived it just
like that gentleman with the awesome
yellow don't fake what you don't you
know certain things you haven't gotten
to in your career yet for example I've
started sprinkling it a little bit I've
been talking more about the year I've
been mentioning lately I don't I've only
a couple times I don't know if you've
heard this but I started to talk about
how I think you have to love your
company at first but then you have to
start bringing candor and merit and I
felt that I mismanaged vaynermedia one
year too late and I created entitlement
and that was a problem for us I needed
to wait a couple years for that year at
the pass
because they didn't want to talk about
something that people were living in my
company at that moment but you know you
haven't lived everything yet so but you
have to talk about it when you do but
you can do it concurrently well where he
talks about focused and how do how do I
actually split mine whose focus who gets
to decide what focuses I have a [ __ ]
wine company a shoe deal content the
vaynermedia [ __ ] Wine Library Gary
Vee [ __ ] baseball cards I'm trying to
sell garage sale I'm the least [ __ ]
focused focused [ __ ] you'll ever meet
guys if you're a real entrepreneur you
kind of can't just do one thing that's
how we're [ __ ] up right like I'm gonna
come up with three business ideas in the
next hour and I'm gonna do that every
day and I'll probably do two of them in
the year because that's what makes us
happy
you can do both and Gary one last
question is what kind of content do i do
do I do like the my restaurants content
what kind of content yes well if you're
trying to impact and help it needs to be
more macro it can't be literal because
most of us don't own restaurants thank
you you're welcome thank you
[Music]
hi Gary I'm Herbert I'm 27 I'm
originally from India been living in
Singapore for the past few years first
of all I just wanted to say I love you
thank you I love you too and so I have a
two-fold question I had a stable job I
let it go a few years ago and I've been
doing things on my own I'm full-time
trader and I've set up an education
business around it it's going pretty
good but you were talking about being
lonely just now so can you talk about
that a bit more especially when it's
very lonely no I'm not but but I'm
getting married in a couple of months so
clearly not yeah so yeah so my question
was lonely as an entrepreneur or doing
your own thing it's a very different
game than having somebody in your life
exactly so that's what I was getting to
in terms of talking about being lonely
when you don't kind of get the support
from your family or from your close
people around you like how do you deal
with that and still I deal with it
extremely well because I love sticking
it to people that don't think I've got
it I mean even if it's your spouse
especially I'm being dead serious guys I
get right
I understand how potentially
disheartening it is when your fiance or
parents or things don't believe in what
you're doing but it makes it so much
more exciting when you achieve it
because then you get to stick it to them
well I've never really thought it that
way but well this is the way to think
about it okay but you don't understand
nobody understands an entrepreneur if
they're not an entrepreneur cuz they
want safe but for you you'd be unhappy
being safe you just lived it yes so I
have empathy for her but you're not
capable of living your life any other
way so here's the best part of the
argument that debate the issue
somebody's gonna be right either you're
gonna go and execute and provide for
your family as an entrepreneur and then
you get to see say to her see or you're
gonna fail and not provide and have
to go get a job and then she gets to say
see right that's the only two options
either your parents are right or you're
right either your husband is right or
you're right
either the commenters in your section or
right or you're right
I spend no time on the cheering or the
boos I spend on executing so that when
it goes to zero zero zero I can say I
was right and just slightly adding on to
that I know you had previous videos
where you talked about handling hate on
social media so kind of acknowledge them
and even start a conversation
yaki positivity into it but how do you
like view address every one of them
because it end of the day it still takes
up your time
yeah I can't address all of my hate
anymore but but I think that to many
people when somebody says something they
don't like to hear dismiss it as hate
and a troll I read it and question it
and then decide is there any merit to it
and the reason I've been able to evolve
is because I don't just default if
somebody disagrees with me or makes fun
of me that they're wrong
I try to be thoughtful about what are
they doing nine out of ten times it's
cuz they're in a bad place and they're
just trying to drag me down but
occasionally there's a point there that
I kind of fester in it and start
subconsciously adjusting what I'm doing
feedback is important perfect thank you
you're welcome
hi Gary one more guys I only have time
for one more question
I apologize hi my name is Reagan so
basically on us as an entrepreneur we
are hustling every single day yes and
sometimes you know we are like
workaholics we don't know when time pass
by yes
but sometimes how do you actually
account for how much you have actually
done or how do you account you know how
productive you have been as an
entrepreneur II for example I could
write one article and I could be very
productive
I could write three active three
articles but I'm not productive so how
do you actually account of you know how
much work I have done as an entrepreneur
you it sounds like you're doing what we
all do which is it sound
like your being your own judge and jury
right so I think you just need to love
yourself more
I'm being serious it's a very
interesting insight like when you were
asking the question I think every day
I'm phenomenal I'm being dead serious
because I'm trying as hard as I can I
have very good intent
I'm really trying and if today was a
less productive day because I was tired
or a meeting didn't go well or who knows
why I'm just not capable of beating
myself up today I'd look at it over the
course of time I mean I you know you get
to be the judge in the jury right right
and one more question is actually about
Millennials actually is that a lot of
times people see that oh these guys too
young or for me as a Singapore any no
it's like you haven't gone are me why
should I listen to you yes and you say
about being authentic yes right but I'm
being authentic and sometimes because
you don't believe I say my experience or
portfolio that was my whole life from 20
to 40 right right so basically it
doesn't be authentic and just share it
or what you just really want to share
what's the alternative make [ __ ] up you
know what I mean
yes look I I am the bottom everything
that you now know me for is nothing I
was saying and doing was accepted when I
was doing it guys I launched an
e-commerce business in 1996 people
thought the internet was a fad email
Google AdWords I started one of the
first YouTube shows ever I invested in
Facebook and Twitter before anybody had
heard heard of it
tumblr like uber like everything I
started having a man follow me with a
camera three years ago people thought
that like everything I do you're gonna
be the but like you can't be upset and
try to convince people who are gonna
judge you on age you just need to move
on to the next person and figure out
which one's not gonna judge you on age
and by the way youngsters take it from
everybody who's over 40 here raise your
hands raise it high us with our hands up
we lived in a world where 100 percent of
20 year olds and 25 year olds were not
listened to because technology became
big you guys are way more respected than
we were at 25 you're over respected I
mean it people think oh you're a kid you
understand technology no you don't so
the reality is you should you've heard a
lot of this today don't be in the
convincing business go to who's already
commenced alright I know what I mean
thank you somebody you got it Gary yes
rushed in last crushed it yep hi I'm
Jillian and I've been following you for
the last one and a half years you're the
only one with the post notifications
turned on on my Instagram thank you and
I love how you're pounding the same
messages every day it's very consistent
and it's very easy to to remember and
follow but also you know I wanted to
bring to a point how do you you talked
about framing contextual creative at
scale how do you do that or do you have
a structure or how do you frame it and I
understand you also mentioned to one of
the ladies Marie something um that you
know Q&A is one of the innovative ways
but what are the other ways aside from
like the three different so what I mean
by that in its most important form is
when you're talking to somebody you need
to relate to them so if you're making a
piece of content to 18 to 20 year olds
you need to use adjectives and cultural
references to an 18 to 20 year old so we
think you know what I mean I mean like
that that's the point the point is you
need to make a contextual to the
audience when I speak here there's a lot
of things that I didn't say today that I
would have definitely said if I was in
New York because it would have made
sense to New Yorkers but wouldn't have
made sense here you know on YouTube I
can make a 41 minute video on Instagram
it was a minute then IG TV came and now
it can be 41 so you have to respect the
platform but first you have to respect
who you're trying to reach so when I say
contextual at scale its
what audience are you trying to reach
and then do you use what slang
what references do you understand yeah
too many people are trying to reach
everybody which means you're not
reaching anybody it's vanilla mm-hmm you
understand so again this is a theme of
this talk when you make so much content
when I make a cop video that says 50
years for the next 50 years
50 year olds you've got 50 more years to
live and the whole video is hey are you
50 are you out of your mind you're still
young let's go let me tell you why
you're gonna live longer which means
you're only halfway but you grew up in
an era where 50 was old when we were
kids and did that no 21 year old is
watching that video maybe they watch it
quickly because they like me and they
pass it to their parent when I make a
video that says [ __ ] your parents the
kids love that the parents are DMing me
like you [ __ ] I'm like you know
so that's what I mean okay so thank you
for coming to my home country Singapore
now what contextual Creator would you do
for this so what kind of slangs do you
have for our Singaporean market the
number one thing that I think about for
this market in this region is the
dynamic of parents pressure on children
it is my number one it is my number one
it is a problem in America
but it is absolutely more prevalent in
Asian countries where parents think kids
success is an indicator on them and they
treat their children like products not
like children thank you for that I agree
with you I actually like quit my
corporate job to train professionally as
an athlete so despite my parents notion
of the ambition and just ran for what I
love I love thank you
Singapore thank you I'm sorry alright
sign
[Applause]